[Music]
we all love emojis there is no better
way to brighten a friend's day than with
a cute little poop emoji with a smiley
face we use emojis every day in almost
every text that we send but what if
you've been using them wrong what if
that cute little smiling emoji doesn't
mean what you think it does at all don't
worry we have rounded up the 10 emojis
that don't mean what you think they mean
to help you out with any confusion if
this is your first time here don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to the things for more great videos home
is where the heart is we've all heard
the saying home is where the heart is
it's in every cliche movie where the
main character leaves home only to
realize that everything they were
looking for was in their own backyard
not to mention all the songs that
feature this famous line so it makes
sense that when people look at the cute
emoji with a heart next to the pink
hotel they assume that it is a picture
description of this infamous quote
you've probably sent it to your mom a
few times while you're on vacation to
tell her you miss home well if you've
been doing that stop immediately that is
not what this emoji means at all in fact
it is a far more dirty meaning it
actually represents a love hotel love
hotels rent out rooms by the hour and
are usually used to accommodate couples
or strangers who want to use it for love
if you know what we mean so if you were
using this emoji often we recommend
removing it from your daily lineup
unless of course you are intending to
meet up with someone to rent out a room
for a little loving then by all means
send to dancing besties there are
certain emojis that we all hold dear to
our hearts the dancing girls emoji is
one of them they just look like they're
so happy and ready to have a good time
they are the perfect emoji to send to
your besties before going out or meeting
up when these two twins pop up in your
inbox you know you're in for a good time
but unfortunately the emoji wasn't
created to be used like we thought no it
doesn't represent two best friends
dancing and having the time of their
life some people believe it depicts two
adult entertainers working which sort of
takes the fun and lightheartedness out
of the emoji others believe that because
of their bunny ears the two girls could
be
human-animal hybrid Hamato Mimi that is
depicted in anime the emoji is available
on almost all operating systems though
it looks slightly different depending on
whether you're using an Android iPhone
or Windows Device regardless of the real
meaning behind the emoji we don't see
anyone slowing down on using it in the
near future how else are you and your
pesty supposed to text about a fun night
out
come on information help desk lady at
first glance this emoji lady looks like
she's simply being sassy just look at
her she looks like she doesn't take
anyone's crap and comes complete with a
hair flip she's anything but sweet most
people use her at the end of a snarky
text message or to show that they're on
top of things she's the number one boss
of emoji land but when she was created
there was a much less snarky identity in
mind she is actually a front desk
information helper her posture is meant
to be seen as attentive she's apparently
supposed to be asking how can I help you
personally we think maybe it would be
more clear if they had thrown some kind
of hat or hotel uniform on her to show
that she was at work right now she still
looks like a sassy hair flipping diva
that we would love to be friends with
and isn't that more fun anyway besides
when would you need to use an
information helped us lady in a text
message it seems a little useless but
we'll keep it in mind next time we're
texting a hotel to make reservations
whenever that is see no evil what's your
favorite emoji
do you like the adorable ones or are the
funny ones more your type well no matter
which emojis are your favorite chances
are you have used this next emoji the
little monkey covering his eyes is one
of the cutest emojis available he seems
to be embarrassed at whatever he saw so
it's only natural that we would think
the emoji was meant to express
embarrassment most people send it when
discussing awkward moments or situations
turns out this monkey emoji is actually
one in the series you've heard of the
popular saying see no evil speak no evil
hear no evil
this monkey represents the see no evil
portion but if you think about it the
two meanings are kind of similar for
instance if you are sending this emoji
to a friend after you walked in on
something you'd rather
I've seen that it makes sense with
either definition and the monkey is just
too cute not to use so the next time
you're hovering over the see no evil
emoji just press cent chances are none
of your friends know the actual meaning
behind the emoji unless you show them
this video of course dead face have you
used the dead face emoji you know the
one we're talking about the one with its
eyes closed and mouth partially opened
kind of resembling a dead fish yeah
that's the one personally it's one of
our favorites most people think that it
is meant to represent a dead person but
in the new age of Millennials Dead has
taken on a whole new meaning it is no
longer equated with an actual loss of
life now people use it to express utter
shock or when they find something
hilarious which brings us to the real
meaning behind this emoji it was meant
to be used to express shock or surprise
so while the two dictionary meanings are
completely opposite in the hands of
Millennials they're actually quite close
so even though the emoji wasn't meant to
express death this new take on the
phrase makes the emoji interchangeable
so now the next time a friend texts you
with their latest news feel free to
continue adding the dead face emoji
besides the words I'm dead they will
know what you mean and the meanings are
so close that no one would probably care
either way
shooting star any astronomy lovers out
there the shooting star emoji has been
the perfect way to add a little star
light to your text you might use it when
suggesting going on a stargazing tour
with your significant other or when
texting your friend about your horoscope
well turns out those stargazing trips
will have to be put on pause because
that's not even close to what that emoji
is supposed to be used for our beloved
shooting star emoji that's supposed to
grant all of our wishes is actually just
an emoji that is supposed to represent
dizziness how boring is that no more
wishing upon this emoji now it will be
reserved for blackouts and times where
you feel nauseous but where is the fun
in that the emoji was modeled after how
cartoons depict dizziness remember all
those cartoons you watched when you were
younger where the bad guy would get
knocked out stars and swirly lines would
usually appear over his head to show
that he was unconscious that is where
the inspiration from this emoji came
from bet you never thought when you were
a kid that you would be using those
dizzy symbols in texts we didn't either
jazz hands
there's no emoji quite as festive as the
jazz-hands emoji think back to every
spirited musical high school or
otherwise that you ever saw what do they
all have in common
jazz hands so when the jazz hands emoji
came out musical theater kids everywhere
rejoiced this emoji is commonly used to
show excitement or some serious dance
moves but if you do a little bit of
research you will see that the emoji of
two hands facing outward is not actually
jazz hands it's actually meant to be a
hug which is crazy because where we are
from hugs typically involve arms but to
each their own so now we guess you'll
just have to write out jazz hands in
your text whenever you're feeling
particularly jazzy but on the bright
side you can now send your friends hugs
through the phone which can never hurt
so the next time your friend texts you
about their recent breakup or another
traumatic event just text the hugging
emoji they may think you're responding
to their sadness with jazz hands so
maybe you should show them this video
beforehand to clear up any confusion
happy hugging blowing a kiss isn't it so
nice to be able to show your loved ones
how much you care about them through
text
there are numerous emojis that show love
and affection there is the heart eyes
emoji an array of colored hearts and
other touchy-feely emojis that just pull
on your heartstrings one of the most
affectionate emojis is the one with the
kissy face and a heart it looks as if
the emoji is blowing a nice gentle kiss
to the person on the other end of the
phone it is normally used the show
carrying infection between friends or
significant others the winky face leads
us to believe that the emoji is a little
naughty so it also seemed appropriate to
use when you wanted to send bay a little
late-night text and while we're close to
what this emoji meant we didn't quite
hit the mark the emoji is not a face
blowing a kiss it's actually throwing it
the emojis official title is face
throwing a kiss which to us seems a
whole lot more violent and less romantic
than blowing a kiss so if you ever want
to assault someone with kisses go ahead
and use this emoji winky face
tongue out the winky face tongue out
emoji is a cult favorite it's just so
ridiculous and fun you'd be hard-pressed
to find someone who doesn't love the
tongue out emoji some people think it's
a sexual emoji because of its silly
nature and like to use it with those
late-night conversations with BAE others
simply use it as a goofy emoji to
express laughter or entertainment for
those people it's pretty much a go to to
express amusement well which version is
right is the emoji funny or sexual we've
got the answer officially titled faced
with stuck out tongue and winking eye
emoji pedia describes this emoji as a
face showing a stuck out tongue winking
at the same time used in an attempt to
be wacky zany or otherwise joking so it
looks like the people who've been using
it jokingly win that's what the emoji
was meant for did you make a mistake and
completely forget something this emoji
is perfect to add on at the end of your
text to describe how goofy it was to
forget now that we know it's real
meaning the emoji works in so many cases
make sure to tell all your friends so
they can make sure they're using it
correctly
- crying laughing well at first glance
the tears in this emoji can cause you to
think that it's sad the emoji is
actually meant to be used in situations
that are so funny it causes you to cry
the emoji is literally crying laughing
officially called tears of joy this
emoji is an all-time favorite
researchers analysed over 70,000 pleats
and came up with a list of the 751 most
used emojis and the top with the tears
of joy emoji so does that mean most
people are so happy that they're crying
most of the
I'm not quite the studies showed that
this correlation has to do with how much
people want to be perceived as happy fun
people this is also the reason why the
top of the list was filled with other
happy emojis people want to seem happy
so they use happy emojis when you think
about it it makes perfect sense often
when we communicate with others we want
to show our happy side and leave out the
negative emojis are a great way to do
that and the crying laughing emoji is
the ultimate happy emoji so next time
you use it just know you're in good
company that's it for the 10 emojis that
don't mean what you think they do do you
know any more emojis with surprised
meanings let us know in the comments and
make sure to share this video with your
friends to save them from making any
texting mistakes bye bye
[Music]